it's late afternoon on a warm winter day
in 1978 and South Korean actress Choi
unhi is walking along a secluded beach
in Hong Kong 40 feet away a woman she
knows stands on the shore motioning her
to come over a few strong-looking men
stand by her side Choi feels uneasy like
something bad is about to happen and
she's right she's been lured here as
Choi walks over to the woman a speedboat
filled with more strong-looking men
pulls up to the shore the men watch as
Choi approaches and when she gets near
they nodded each other they grab her and
they force her into the boat their
destination
North Korea
[Music]
Choi was kidnapped to be forced to star
in movies for the North Korean leader
Kim Jong-il
this is a story about film and Cinema in
the scariest country on Earth North
Korea